i'm so grateful and i'm so proud of
these projects and it was really
difficult and now we know why making the
50 shade saga was difficult after dakota
johnson reveals behind the scenes
clashes with franchise author e.l james
i had notes and the producer said notes
and pulls back the curtain on what she
calls mayhem behind the scenes i felt
brave enough to do that role but i
really needed
to feel safe in a profile for vanity
fair the actress says she hasn't been
able to talk about these experiences
until now christian green i'm anastasia
steele years after her breakout role in
the first film in the trilogy fifty
shades of grey dakota confesses she
quote signed up to do a very different
version of the film we ended up making
i emailed my manager at the time i think
i want to audition for that i feel like
it could be really cool so what happened
it was challenging it wasn't always a
smooth road sometimes rocky for dakota
e.l james who penned the best-selling
book series wielded a little too much
influence over the screenplay she tells
the mag she had a lot of creative
control all day every day and she just
demanded certain things happen i was a
producer on the film i was there
yeah every day she explains quote we'd
do the takes of the movie that eel
wanted to make and then we would do the
takes of the movie that we wanted to
make it was mayhem all the time i'd
never talked to anyone about us anyway
she added it was always a battle always
and remember when charlie hunnam was
originally cast as christian grey i did
some work sessions with the with the um
director in dakota my co-star in the
movie well dakota recalls the original
script was essentially thrown out after
charlie exited the project he was
ultimately replaced by jamie dornan
but one scene from the original
screenplay made it into the final film
the sexual contract discussion between
anastasia and christian also on page
five there are some terms which need
clarification
suspension
hanging on ropes from the ceiling
for what possible reason
for your pleasure
really dakota calls it the best scene in
the whole movie and despite the
behind-the-scenes drama dakota says e-l
was always kind to her i know what i
signed up for and looking back on the
experience now she has no regrets if i
had known at the time that's what it was
going to be like i don't think anyone
would have done it but no i don't regret
it this outlook echoes what dakota told
et in 2020 telling us the bumps in the
road are all part of the journey when i
was out of high school i started
auditioning and
um
started working pretty soon after i
graduated and then i guess we'd call my
my big break
50 shades those
changed things for me on a pretty
epic scale
but
there's been a lot of twists and turns
on the way and
and uh
and i'm so grateful for all of them
[Music]